[Music]
so
[Music]
good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us it's
a huge pleasure to welcome secretary of
state lincoln to the uk
uh tony it's great to have you here with
us warm welcome
i think it's fair to say the biden
administration is barely 100 days old
but
has already taken a huge number of bold
and very welcome steps on issues like
climate change
global health and human rights and
that's really created
momentum in efforts to tackle these
pressing global issues
since tony's confirmation we've been
working very closely together
and today's meeting has been another
reminder of the depth and breadth of the
work
that we do together the convergence of
our interests and the
many shared values so today tony and i
discuss the full range of issues i'll
give you a highlight of
i think some of the key points we talked
about our shared commitment to stand up
for open societies democracy and human
rights
protecting fundamental freedoms tackling
disinformation
holding human rights abusers to account
we talked uh a key element of this is
defending the rule of law so we're
determined to reform but reinforce the
multilateral system
we want to keep working together very
closely uh on all of these points
through the g7
and president biden's democracy summit
we also discuss china i think it's fair
to say we see eye to eye on the need to
stand up for our values
holding beijing to the commitments that
they've made whether it's in relation to
hong kong under the joint declaration or
or wider commitments whilst also at the
same time finding constructive ways to
work with china
in a sensible and positive manner where
that's possible
that's important i think on global
issues like climate change
we want to see china stepping up to the
plate and playing its full role
antonia and i also discussed a whole
range of security issues iran
afghanistan
continuing concerns about russia in
particular on the border with ukraine
we stand shoulder to shoulder on these
issues and uh i welcome the us's
firm recommitment to the nato alliance
it's only by working together overseas
that we can keep our citizens safe at
home and i think that's true
in nato and i think it's true uh on
covid and
the various measures that we're taking
uh to extend and expand and promote
kovacs
secretary secretary blinken and i will
see the prime minister tomorrow to
continue the discussions that we've had
one of the major areas of common
interest is building a
broader and stronger set of partnerships
among countries that
share our values on the most important
issues of the day
so the g7 foreign and development
ministers meeting which begins today is
a
great opportunity to really drive that
agenda forward
this is the first opportunity for all g7
foreign ministers to meet together in
person
since 2019 so i think we're glad to be
able to
socialize a bit together and conduct
those meetings face to face rather than
just doing it all on zoom and teams
and i think it's it's also fair to say
that the world's changed quite a bit
in those two short years our societies
our economies have been shocked and
shaken by
coronavirus at the same time we're
responding to
a situation where our values are being
challenged the international
architecture is at least in some
respects being weakened
and there's also the rapid technological
change which brings new opportunities
we've seen that with the collaboration
on things like the vaccine
but also acute challenges and there are
global threats from
covid to climate change that frankly
demand global solutions and we're
committed to trying to find
and forge those solutions so in that
context we recognize the importance of
building dynamic agile new partnerships
with like-minded countries that share
our values
and that's why we invited the foreign
ministers from india south korea
australia and brunei brunei also
obviously representing asean as the
chair
and they'll be taking part later on in
the week they're all key partners for us
i think they're also a sign of the
growing focus on the indo-pacific region
as the economic and strategic crucible
uh for this century
and that's the g7 well at its core it's
a partnership based on values and so
it's
fitting that today we meet
on world press freedom day and we've
seen a whole range of attacks on
journalists
from belarus to myanmar violations of
media freedoms are growing around the
world
at what i feel is an alarming rate and
i welcome the unequivocal stance of the
united states
and the whole g7 on safeguarding those
vital democratic bulwarks in our media
freedoms
as co-chair of the global media freedom
coalition
the uk is working with our partners so
that we shine a light on the violations
uh we hold those to account we support
journalists who are trying to shine
a light on those abuses around the world
and
we try and reverse what is otherwise a
dangerous trend
this cuts i think to the core of the
values and the interest that the g rep
g7 represents right around the world and
it shows
again i think why it's so important for
us to meet together uh this week
now let me hand over to tony tony again
thanks for being here thanks for our
valuable discussions
today and i look forward and we look
forward to welcoming president biden
to the uk in june and i'm looking
forward to a productive g7 meeting this
week
thank you very much dominic let me let
me actually just
start where where dominic left off which
is
uh world press freedom day um which
uh i have to tell you i i take very much
to heart
personally as well as professionally i
actually started my career
as a journalist from the relatively safe
confines of washington dc
but as dominic said i think we're seeing
every day the work that uh
journalists are doing around the world
in increasingly difficult and
challenging conditions
to inform people
to hold governments and leaders of one
kind or another
accountable nothing is more fundamental
to the good functioning of our
democracies
um and i think we're both resolute
um in our support uh for uh for a free
press
uh and so it's uh it's fitting that we
uh actually are addressing
our colleagues from the press on this
day and i have to tell you it's
particularly
uh good to be in london uh for the first
time
as secretary of state i i realized in in
thinking about it that
the first time i came to uh the united
kingdom in london was almost exactly 50
years ago
and many many times since but it's
especially good to be here today and
especially good
dominic to have the chance to spend some
real uh real time with you
uh we've we've already met twice i think
in person at nato we've been on the
phone
uh innumerable times uh but there's
nothing quite like being face to face
we're sometimes masked to mask
uh and um i'm particularly pleased that
we've had an opportunity that uh here
today and this will extend on for the
next uh
the next few days and to your point
president biden is very much looking
forward
uh to being here for the g7 in just a
little over a month
uh and i'm also looking forward to the
opportunity to meet with with prime
minister johnson
uh tomorrow very much appreciate that
right
right next door um i also do want to
take a moment to say um in person
uh what i said in private including to
dominic which is to offer
my own condolences and deep sympathy on
the passing
of his royal highness prince philip duke
of edinburgh
this year is the 80th anniversary of the
atlantic charter
which set the foundation for the
international rules-based order
that our countries so strongly subscribe
to
and which is uh as a result of the the
openness
security and economic possibility uh
it's created
been a tremendous advantage for not only
the citizens of our countries but for
people
around the world it's also the 75th
anniversary
of winston churchill's famous speech at
westminster college in missouri
where he described the special
relationship between the united kingdom
and the united states
and how vital it is for our two
countries
and many others around the world
three quarters of a century later that
special relationship
is enduring it's effective it's dynamic
and it is close to the hearts of the
american people
the work we do together serves our
people's interests across a vast array
of issues many of which dominate
touchdown including
maintaining our national security
rejuvenating our economies
on a sustainable and more equitable
basis
i think our bilateral relationship is
also vital to the world
the work that we do together advances
progress on the most urgent global
issues and global issues that are having
a real impact on the lives of our
citizens including stopping covet 19
addressing the threat of climate change
defending democratic values
and open societies as dominic said we're
going to address these topics over the
next several days
with our counterparts in the g7 and
dominic i want to thank you and the
united kingdom
not just for hosting us but for your
leadership
in building an incredibly robust agenda
that again is centered on issues that
have a real impact
on the lives of our fellow citizens uh
we'll focus on ending the coveted 19
pandemic worldwide
and the united kingdom shares our
commitment uh to ensuring that the world
is better
prepared to prevent detect
and respond to the next pandemic
we also have to lead a global economic
recovery that's sustainable and that
matches growth with equity
so that the people hardest hit by the
economic impact of cobit
are helped and it aligns also with the
urgent need
to reduce emissions and build a green
economy so we can rise to the challenge
of climate change
to that end here in london we'll discuss
how the world's major economies
need to raise ambitions on climate
action
and i commend the united kingdom for its
new 2035 target
which sets an appropriately high bar uh
we'll talk about threats
to the international rules based order
and to democratic values and
human rights uh together our two
countries recently took measures to
prevent
british and american businesses from
inadvertently supporting forced labor in
xinjiang
and elsewhere in china uh we'll continue
our robust cooperation
to address the atrocities in xinjiang uh
a crackdown on pro-democracy activists
and politicians in hong kong uh which
breaches china's international
commitments
uh and the repression of media freedom
across china and
in other parts of the world i also want
to thank
the united kingdom for joining us in
holding russia
to account for its reckless and uh
aggressive actions
we have reaffirmed our unwavering
support for the independent sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine uh
which i'll be visiting
later this week uh also
welcome the foreign secretary's recent
announcement on the extension of global
magnitsky sanctions
to combat russian human rights uh abuses
as dominic said our two countries are
fully committed to nato
and to maintaining transatlantic unity
in defense of our common values
and in response to direct threats um
one final issue i'll just mention is
northern ireland the united states
remains a steadfast supporter
of a secure and prosperous northern
ireland in which all communities have a
voice
and can enjoy the gains of the hard-won
peace
like several u.s presidents before him
president biden has been unequivocal in
his support for the good friday
agreement
which was a historic achievement and one
that we should protect
um there's much more that i could say
about all the work that
the united states and the united kingdom
do every single day
uh in ways uh uh quiet uh and otherwise
to to serve the interests
of our people and i believe the broader
international community we're connected
uh it's often said but always important
uh to
to reaffirm uh we're connected by ties
of friendship
family history shared values
and shared sacrifice we've been reminded
that again in recent weeks
as we prepare to draw down our forces
from afghanistan we've stood
shoulder to shoulder for nearly 20 years
sharing a mission and having each
other's backs
we'll never forget it the united states
has no closer ally
no closer partner than the united
kingdom and i'm very glad for the chance
to say that again here today
thank you tony thanks very much
uh okay we'll take uh some questions
from the media and i think
if the tech is working we've got james
landale from the bbc up first
james over to you i'm huge
foreign secretary uh secretary blinken
good afternoon uh foreign first of all
what is your assessment of reports out
of iran yesterday suggesting a deal was
being agreed to secure the release of
nazim sagari radcliff
and that the tank debt was being paid
and secondly
foreign secretary you are cutting
british foreign aid to yemen
to syria to the united nations children
fund the u.n population fund
the u.n aids fund water sanitation
hygiene polio eradication
conflict resolution humanitarian
preparedness and girls education
how can britain claim to show global
leadership at the g7
when it is cutting so much foreign aid
and secretary blinken if i may what is
your assessment of reports of a prisoner
swap deal
between the u.s and iran secondly how
much damage do you think has been caused
by britain's decision to
cut its foreign aid budget and thirdly
do you think the g7
is fit for purpose thank you
james thanks for that um look we are on
the detainees and the situation of
nazanin obviously we're working very
intensively to try and secure their
release we have been for many months
um uh i would say that uh it's incumbent
on iran
uh unconditionally to release those who
have held
arbitrarily and in our view unlawfully
um
and the the reports i'm afraid are not
yet uh accurate in terms of her
uh the suggestion of her imminent
release on aid uh james
we even after the cuts that we've had to
make not
because of the pressing covert situation
the biggest contraction of our economy
for 300 years
double the budget deficit we faced after
uh the financial crash
we're still putting 10 billion pounds in
as a proportion of gdp still the third
biggest g7 donor doubling our
international
climate finance uh contribution uh the
biggest
uh uh one of the biggest bilateral uh
humanitarian donors
the biggest uh donor to gavi
so i appreciate it's been a difficult
decision um but i think actually if you
look at all the areas and all the
positives that we are still contributing
to
actually i think it shows the scope for
us to be an even greater force for good
in the world
but what we need to do is work with our
partners uh in order to magnify and
amplify
those efforts and that's what the g7 is
all about
great um well thank you very much and
uh to to dominic's point with regard to
our detained citizens uh
in iran first this is something that uh
that we raise
at every opportunity i have no uh higher
priority
than bringing arbitrarily detained
americans
uh american hostages home to the united
states
and that's across the board and as
dominic said the reports
coming out of tehran are are not
accurate uh
we are very closely engaged uh ourselves
uh on this issue
and uh will remain so uh and as i said
i'm determined to bring
every american home more broadly uh
on this uh we have to take
a stand against the arbitrary detention
of uh citizens for for political
purposes i
applaud the work that canada has done uh
in this area and uh dominic and i
discussed this as well today
and i would hope that um uh with time
and effort
countries could establish a norm
that this practice is simply
unacceptable
uh because it is and uh i think we'll
have conversations in the coming weeks
and coming months
uh about that uh countries that um
engage in these actions uh need to know
that that cannot happen with impunity
and it is uh truly unacceptable i have
to tell you as well
that uh from from washington's
perspective
um the uh the uk is uh our most
vital partner including working around
the world uh
in uh helping uh other countries
uh helping people uh fulfill their
potential
and deal with some of the challenges
that have been uh
brought on by uh many things but
including by covet 19 now
uh as well as the uh the climate crisis
and
um i think we share
a commitment both in our own countries
but in the work that we're doing around
the world
to as both the president and prime
minister have recently said
build back better and we see both
necessity but also opportunity
uh in um in the weeks and months ahead
to do
just that to restore growth but to do it
in
a more equitable fashion uh to focus on
uh addressing
through building back better the climate
crisis that we have to address and
finding opportunity in that
with good new jobs based on on green
technology
and of course we share a commitment to
and conviction
about the importance of um uh doing
development work
in in different ways and amplifying as
dominic said
uh both our respective contributions as
well as bringing others along
and to your question i think the g7 is
is
very fit for purpose and it's especially
fit for purpose
uh right now we're seeing this in the
leadership uh of the united kingdom
in producing this incredibly robust
agenda and also
bringing other critical countries uh
into the mix so that we can
i hope uh amplify the uh
the effect we're having amplify the
amplify the results
thanks james thanks very much i think
next on the list is sean tandon from afp
sean
sean you're on mute
there we go
still not still on mute sean
sorry can you hear me now loud and clear
great my apologies uh you talked about
the asia pacific being that there's been
a quite an emphasis this week
uh to secretary blinken the policy
review that's just come out on north
korea
how hopeful are you
i think we lost you again um could you
repeat that i'm sorry about that can you
hear me down yes go ahead please
i'm sorry about that uh north korea the
policy review that has uh that that was
recently completed by the white house
uh do you believe secretary blinken that
uh that there's some hope for a
resumption of diplomacy with north korea
or to return to diplomacy despite the
reaction that we've seen so far from
north korea
uh mr foreign secretary if you also have
any thoughts on north korea and if both
of you have thoughts on the situation in
myanmar slash burma
uh we've seen an upsurge an uptick in
ethnic violence violence by ethnic
fighters there have been
persistent killians of protesters
international results if expressed here
will it have an effect thank you very
much thank you very much
um on north three yes you're exactly
right we completed uh the the policy
review and
we we conducted this review very uh
deliberately um in in two ways
first with the recognition that this is
an incredibly hard problem
and um to state the obvious uh it
it is yet to be solved from
administration to administration
democrat and uh and republican uh over
the years and so we wanted to take
account
uh that history to look at what uh uh
what works what doesn't work uh and how
we could have an effective policy to
advance the goal that we have
which is the complete denuclearization
of the korean peninsula second we did it
in a deliberate way because we wanted to
make sure
that we were very actively consulting
with all of the concerned countries
starting with our close allies uh south
korea and japan
uh given their own very strong equities
in
um uh in this issue
and so we did that we took the time to
do that and
what we have now is a policy that calls
for a
calibrated practical approach that is
open to
and will explore diplomacy with uh north
korea
to try to make practical progress uh
that increases the security of the
united states
our allies and our deployed forces
and as we're doing that uh we will
continue to be in very close
coordination and consultation
with uh with allies and partners
starting with the republic of korea and
japan
as well as others along the way uh
i hope that uh uh north korea will
uh take the opportunity to engage
uh diplomatically and uh to see if there
are uh
ways to move forward toward the
objective of complete denuclearization
of
the korean peninsula uh and so we'll
look to see
uh not only what uh north korea says but
what it actually does
uh in the coming uh days and months but
we have uh
i think a clear uh a very clear policy
that uh
centers on uh diplomacy uh and uh
it is uh i think up to uh for north
korea to decide whether it wants to
engage
or not on that basis
uh sure look we share the strategic
paradigm that tony set out
we'll support and supplement those
efforts uh
as conducted by the us and of course our
friends and partners in
in the region on myanmar look we want to
see an end to
the violence we want to see
the military regime return to democracy
and
the electoral mandate that the
government should have representing the
people of myanmar
we've been cleared not just in our
targeted sanctions our magnitsky
sanctions but also
wider measures we're taking to stop uk
businesses
uh doing business with conglomerates or
businesses controlled by the tapmador
that we're going to apply pressure that
way equally we've been engaged with the
partners of the region i've been
discussing that with asean foreign
ministers recently and
uh we've obviously got the opportunity
with the g7 guests here from
korea from uh india from australia but
also the promise from brunei
chair of the uh of asean at the moment
to discuss
how we shift the dial and get a a change
for the better in
in myanmar um and so we'll keep up all
of those efforts on the sanctions side
but also on the on the diplomacy turned
out i don't know whether you want to add
anything on myanmar no i think that
covered it very well other than to
to add that uh the uh
five-point plan uh or agreement that
that asean reached i think is uh
is important and we are looking uh to uh
uh asean to move forward uh
with that plan including uh designating
uh an envoy
uh from the end and get person to
myanmar to be able to engage
all of uh all of the parties
but it is vital regardless of anything
else
that the violence cease that uh
prisoners be released
and that myanmar returned to uh to the
path of democracy
and uh i subscribed to everything that
uh the dominic said about some of the
things that we're
we're doing or looking at to encourage
that
sean thanks very much next up we got
lucy fisher from the telegraph lucy
thank you two quick questions if i may
firstly on northern ireland
secretary of state blinken you said the
u.s supports the good friday agreement
but i wanted to ask you and foreign
secretary rob how secure
you each view the agreement as being and
whether the northern ireland protocol
should be renegotiated to help maintain
peace
secondly on afghanistan are you not each
concerned about an explosion of violence
an occurring of refugees
following the us exit of troops and
secretary blinken
isn't washington in effect ignoring
allies like britain
where the head of the military has
voiced misgivings over this troop
drawdown
let me just say on northern ireland uh
we the good friday agreement is
absolutely crucial
uh uh to peace we also we also recognize
and appreciate the
us contribution to it and uh the state
that that america feels that they're
having a good friday agreement
and i want to be at the center of what
we do going forward
in terms of the northern ireland
protocol um lucy
obviously there are bits of it that
protect the eu equities around the
single market
bits that protect the integrity of the
single market of the united kingdom
we've got to make sure in the joint
committee we're pragmatic we work
through all of these
proposals we implement them in a
balanced way um and that's the approach
that we take going forward including
with our european partners and our
friends in dublin and
indeed um with our american partners
on afghanistan just to be clear from a
uk perspective we
do not feel ignored by our u.s partners
we've had very good consultation
on this and we continued that we
discussed it today we certainly see the
priority is protecting our
uh troops uh in the period between now
and september
uh making sure that we uh preserve the
ability to deal with counter-terrorism
that
the gains that were hard won in
afghanistan uh
are not lost and also ultimately
promoting uh
dialogue and a peace process that
benefits all afghans and uh
leaves afghanistan as stable as possible
as inclusive as possible
uh and uh lucy just just as i
mentioned in the opening remarks uh we
very much welcome the provisions
uh in both the trade deal between uh the
united kingdom and the european union
uh as well as the northern ireland
protocol uh
that will help protect the gains of the
uh of the good friday uh agreement
as uh the united kingdom the european
union begin implementing uh the
brexit-related provisions
uh we will uh continue to encourage them
to prioritize
political and economic stability in
northern ireland
with regard to to afghanistan
as we work toward the decision
that president biden made
we spent a good deal of time very
actively consulting
uh with our uh our nato partners and
nato allies and uh
you know as i noted uh dominic and i
were in brussels uh together on
on a couple of occasions both in advance
of that decision and
as the decision was being announced we
were on the phone
uh regularly as well uh talking about
this
and nato uh made a commitment
nato allies made a commitment to each
other and to our partners in together
adapt together
out together and that's exactly what
we're doing with an emphasis
on the word together nato issued a
unanimous
statement both in support of president
uh biden's decision
and taking note of the actions that uh
allies and partners would take
at the same time as dominic said we are
very focused
on a deliberate safe and orderly
uh drawdown of our forces we've made
absolutely clear
that as we uh withdraw forces from
afghanistan
we will protect them and if they are
attacked
we will take decisive action in response
but we've also been clear that even as
our forces are
drawing down and pulling out of
afghanistan we are not
uh withdrawing we are not uh disengaging
uh we intend uh to be very active
uh diplomatically in terms of trying to
advance
negotiations in a political settlement
between the government of afghanistan
the taliban
and other key parties
we intend to sustain our assistance to
uh to afghanistan
including uh development economic
humanitarian our support for
uh afghanistan's security forces as well
and all of that we're doing in very
close coordination
and very close collaboration not only
with the united kingdom
but with uh dozens of other countries
that share
uh that same commitment lucy thank you
very much
and finally on the list we've got
michael crowley from the new york times
michael
thank you so much thank you both for
doing this president trump was very
interested in seeing russia rejoin the
g7
that idea now seems clearly off the
table
at the same time president biden and
other president biden and other g7
leaders have said
there are many shared interests with
moscow including climate and iran
and mr biden is planning to meet with
president putin soon
is there any consideration for including
russia at these gatherings
even informally at some point meanwhile
china was also not invited even as other
several other major non-g7 nations were
so
more broadly would it be right to see
this gathering as an early incarnation
of a broader democratic alliance which
aims to counterbalance the autocracies
of china and russia
um so from a uk perspective look the
door for
positive relations and diplomacy is
always open to us and i
i think that's something shared across
uh many of the
the nato countries uh but what's got to
change is
russia's behavior uh against as a p5
member of the security council against
the basic norms of international law
whether it's
the brinkmanship and the sabre rattling
on the border with ukraine
uh whether it's the cyber attack attacks
and the misinformation
uh or indeed uh the poisoning of alexey
navalny which was not just a human
rights abuse but
a chemical use of chemical weapons on
russian soil so the opportunity for a
better relationship with russia
is there we would welcome it but it
depends on behavior and deeds
on the second question i'm not sure i'm
quite as theological
uh as the the michael as you were in the
way you put it
but i do see uh the increasing demand
and need the agile clusters of
like-minded countries
that share the same values uh and want
to protect the multilateral system and i
think you can see that
in the guests that we brought in uh to
the g7
korea south korea um india australia and
south africa
and uh so in that organic sense i think
we can see a shift towards that pattern
of clusters of like-minded
countries agile enough to work together
uh
and uh michael as with most things uh
dominic and i are in violent agreement
um let me just add a couple of quick
words about both
both russia and china uh with regard to
russia as dominic said
we are focused uh very much on on
russia's actions
and what course uh it chooses to take
uh president biden has been very clear
for a long time including before he was
president
that if russia chooses to uh act
recklessly or aggressively we'll respond
but we're not looking to escalate we
would
prefer to have a more stable more
predictable
relationship and if russia moves in that
direction
so will we and i think president biden
will have an opportunity when he meets
with president putin
to talk about that directly and indeed
there are areas where
uh it is manifestly in the interests of
both countries
to uh to try to find ways to work
together strategic stability
uh probably being at the at the top of
the list and indeed already
despite the profound differences uh that
we have
we managed to extend the new start
agreement by five years uh we'll look
for other opportunities but to dominic's
point this is really a function
of what russia chooses to do or not to
and with regard to china let me let me
add i fully subscribe to everything that
the dominic said um let me just add one
uh
other uh quick thought uh
it is not our purpose to try to contain
china or or to hold uh china down what
we're trying to do
is to uphold the international
rules-based order
that our countries have invested so much
in over so many decades
to the benefit i would argue not just of
our own citizens but of people around
the world including
by the way china and
when any country
china or otherwise takes actions that
challenge
or undermine or seek to erode that
rules-based order
and not make good on the commitments
that they've made
to that order we will um we will stand
up
and uh and defend the order i think we
also have a responsibility
to offer and uh
and develop a positive vision for the
future that
brings countries together in common
purpose and a lot of the work
uh that we're doing notably through the
g7 uh
is exactly that uh ultimately as as
president biden
said the other night when he was
addressing congress i think the
challenge
uh for us uh is to demonstrate
in very concrete ways that we can
deliver uh for our citizens for the
the people that uh we uh we've been
asked to represent
uh and when we're looking at most of the
challenges that that we face
that actually have an impact on their
lives uh whether it's this pandemic
whether it is uh a changing climate
whether it's the disruptive impact of
new technologies
not a single one of those challenges can
be effectively met by any one country
acting alone even the united states even
the united kingdom
there is a i think a stronger imperative
than at any time since i've been
involved
in these issues to find ways for
countries to
uh cooperate to coordinate to
collaborate
that's the way uh we advance the
interests of
of our citizens and the work that uh
dominic the united kingdom are doing
through their um presidency of the the
g7 that's exactly
what it's designed to do and we're very
grateful to be a partner in that
enterprise
michael thank you very much i think that
brings the questions to a close
uh folks thanks for joining us and that
brings the press conference to a
conclusion thank you all very much